the grand dom season six has arrived
and how are you feeling about your sixth
ride on the housewives carousel i've
enjoyed the ride i
i think coming off of season five you
know that's pretty rough reunion
but i think we have to understand and
respect that decisions were made
and move on i mean the pandemic put
everything in perspective i believe
yeah i was going to ask how the pandemic
affected kind of the dynamics of the
group do you feel like it brought you
closer together or did it cause
more problems we were actually on top of
each other the entire time in the
pandemic so
i thought it actually uh was a two-edged
sword it
caused us to have conversations that we
probably didn't want to have but to grow
from that because we had to have them
so it brought us closer together as a
group completely i know i feel that way
you mentioned this very tense season
five reunion
we ended with things between you and
candace in
not a great place why would i
assassinate you that way if i cared
about you
i don't believe this yeah
did you stay in that place as the season
started is that the place we had to work
from
listen mia the new girl candice
wendy ashley uh
all of us are in a much better place
because
of this so you have to stay tuned for
candice and my growth and how we work
through that because there's a love
between candace and i
as far as gisele well
you don't see much just you know you
don't see much change
um but you see i see a lot of growth and
my friendship with the ladies just
blossomed this season and i'm so happy
about that
and i can't give you much but i say stay
tuned for candace and i'm
okay i know we have people rooting for
us there are people rooting for you that
was i put out a call for questions and
that was the number one question is
will these two get back to the place
they once were
it sounds like maybe you might not be
there yet
or maybe you're beyond that i would say
that you know
maybe getting back to where we were
wasn't strong enough i liked that
okay so stay tuned and we've seen from
the teasers we know
that conversation continues right now i
don't trust you
we know we're gonna get to see that very
difficult conversation that needed to be
had
and that was the point where growth
starts you'll see that
obviously that was all tied up in the
monique of it all monique chose to
remove herself from this group
where do things between you and monique
stan now and how do you feel about her
not being a part of this group anymore
again bryce you know decisions were made
that need to be understood and respected
and move on my relationship with monique
i'm not a fair weather friend i
am a constant person i'm able to
have a friendship with her but put that
in perspective
and separate it from the origin and and
i respect my friend enough to do that
you mentioned we've got a new girl on
the block miss mia who i understand
comes to this group by way of you yes
she does
chimney cricket i'm telling you mia is a
breath
of fresh air i said it before we
actually met through a business
associate
and i just knew that everyone would like
her she is a hoot and and she's
likeable and a breath again a fresh air
did you get to know her better through
this experience of her becoming part of
this group did your friendship grow
from this experience you know me and i
had a friendship thank you for asking
that uh prior to the show
i can tell you the show certainly gives
you that opportunity to learn more about
your friends
and i learned so much more about mia and
i can say this
maybe none of it turned me off it made
me smile okay
and and we but we're real with our
friendship so
you know we don't always agree on
everything but she and i when we're in
the moment
you'll see that we talk about things in
the moment we don't let it get by we
don't
bury it and pick it up five weeks later
no we handle it then
so i enjoy my relationship and my
friendship with me
how did you feel about um the salad toss
that is quite the moment
but that tossing of the salad was
everything for me i was like if you saw
me in the teaser i was like what just
happened
uh but those are the things that make me
like mia more because she's
unexpected joy you know and she's
on point and i like that you know she
always surprises me
what can you tell me about what leads us
to that moment it's something between
her and candles that's all we know
there's a lot of listening that needs to
be done during the
frosting of the salad that may not have
happened at the tossing of the salads
yeah i was there for the whole thing i
was like father god
giselle recently gave an interview where
she said she had a rocky start with mia
and blamed you for that
but now you know why she had like a
little bit of a rocky start with me
because karen's in her ear
right like you know that one right there
you don't need to be friends with her
so but we got that situated she speaks
louder than words for herself
and there's not much change just stay
tuned isn't that same interview where
she
uh said she had a rocky start with mia
she did say that the two of you were
in a good place after filming uh season
six
how are you and karen now karen today we
are good
today listen i'm all for
people making authentic efforts to
better themselves and to be a good
friend um i'm all for that
uh and i you know i'm just very wise so
that has to be proven to me um but you
know i'm hopeful
uh that it's real this time and that we
can
get on to a better place so i'm always
open but honey i got a third eye on jizz
consciously optimistic at an arm's
length we are right for
now is what she actually said i'm on
pause and i'm ready honey at all times
for your
on you know all right for now not to be
genuine
am i wasting my time with that no i had
a ball with all of the other ladies
we grew fantastically close i love each
and every one of them and i
am in a place of acceptance of giselle
wherever she is
you said there's some growth this season
does that growth include growth in the
wardrobe department how are her fashions
this year
i think her fashion speaks for
themselves just stay tuned and watch it
i mean
i want to give her a fair shake but you
know
just look at it you you determine okay i
don't need to
drag her uh wardrobe uh because it
speaks for itself
we see in the trailer you tell her honey
you got dragged then you let him back in
and he dragged you again
what was your reaction to the man in the
phone essentially proving he was just
a man in the phone i felt sorry for her
i
felt like she got dragged again jamal
lives in your phone i know
that because he lives in my life that's
unfortunate
um but again my focus was not on her
disproving the life that she put out
last year about this fake relationship
it was about moving on with my group of
friends so that we could survive
after all we had been through a very
difficult year it could not have been
about her this year
so i handle her when necessary uh
but i certainly don't waste time on her
there's so much more beautiful pockets
in each and every
one of my friends on this show and i'm
so excited for everyone to meet them
we're not quite done with gisele yet
because we know she steps in the mess
she doesn't mind stepping in the mess we
see in the trailer
she brings up these eddie rumors
so when are we going to talk about the
eddie rumors
what do we need to know about these
so-called rumors going into the season
you know
i personally don't get into spreading
rumors i'm friends with wendy
i support she and her husband eddie
wendy and i by the way have grown
i'll teach you with that tremendously
this season so the respect that i have
for their marriage and family
would be one that says if wendy came to
me and said i had a problem i had a
problem
i'm not one that reads blogs and makes
the tv
i got enough tv right here i was gonna
ask you because
season five i remember doing an
interview much like this and you
were meh on wendy you were unimpressed
so it seems that um she has impressed
you at this point
you know what i will say that rudy and i
impressed each other because what we did
is wrong women is we took out the
negative
person who didn't want us to get closer
and we dared to take a look at one
another
and we grew from them and i would
imagine that was a green eyed bandit in
between
it is what it is um we
hear wendy seemingly tell giselle in
like that trailer them yeah miss wendy
you know and your question is what
does she make good on that promise you
have to stay tuned
you have to stay tuned i i think she
does good at
representing a woman a black woman in
particular that loves her husband
um and how dare you keep coming for our
husbands when you don't have one for us
to return served to
i'm just saying don't touch anything
that you don't bring to the page
how about that there it is who would you
say has the toughest
season uh in season six ooh
my heart goes out to wendy and uh it
actually
caused me to pour into wendy
what i was raised to do when you see a
sister going through
um so yeah that brought me closer to her
uh with the compassion that i felt for
her in
those moments it's not just one it's so
many moments
okay who has the best season i think
collectively
we all do um not just one of us makes
rhop rdp
we all collectively do that so
we all are bringing great story
great personal life and great drama and
i'm so proud of each and
every one of my friends on this show and
you know it also takes the drama from
people like
this to do what she does without any
conscious
uh well you know we gotta hope for jits
you know
how does how does she feel about you
referring to her as jizz
i've never asked her i didn't ask for
permission i'll make a note to ask her
next time i talk to her
last season was a tough one for you and
ray
how is the institution doing today 2021
ray is a handful this season i don't
know what he thought he was going to get
when he asked me to marry him again
i mean so you'll see that unravel step
by step by step and he's very involved
we are buried together but not without
discussion honey we we worked on this
relationship and the pandemic brought us
closer
but that wedding woo getting there
you'll see just buckle up before we get
to that
did seeing how he treated you on camera
last year did he apologize ray did
apology
and that meant the world to me so i was
very grateful for that but
along with that apology i accepted some
responsibility in this relationship
which
made it uh made it better for us
uh because our communication continues
our friendship continues
our foundation is there and our
institution is you know here it's still
here so i'm very very grateful that
while it was painful to share with the
viewers it drew us closer together as
family
uh including our children so i got a
gift through that struggle
we know the season is leading to this
wedding you're teasing this vow renewal
karen those historically do not have the
best track record in the universe of
housewives
you know uh andy cohen uh told me that
season five and i stopped 10 minutes
since i want to stop you now i have done
everything i can to not
make it the wedding that i had 25 years
ago
so stay tuned i do different things i
i'll give you a teaser you know how the
woman comes down the aisle
mm-hmm i put a cherry on that and you'll
see what i do i climb something
okay hello so no regrets about doing a
vowel renewal
no no you know listen let me say this
price i've heard all the taboos but
if it fails it's going to fail anymore
it's not going to be because of some
uh wedding or me skipping the second
time going down
i don't know it just doesn't work so i
don't believe in the tampo
all right a couple last questions there
are some other moments in this trailer
that i just
i need some teases on oh lord why do you
say
i should be able to show my pubic hair
oh lord lord look
i'll say this here here's my teaser on
that particular event that we were at
this
thing we were doing as a group sex was
hot on the topic
body image this the that so i'm a very
confident woman
and i just got tired of listening to
some of the things that i did not agree
with and so i just simply stated that i
should be able to show the hairs if i
needed to
and you should support me because you're
my girl okay
who or what is sing sing everyone knows
that's why we went to sing sing
i gotta say in the moment i was sensing
flew out my mouth i gotta be
and i i and i own it you know i have a
great comedic timing
and when i find myself being drawn into
someone else's darkness
i have to put a sense of comedic spin on
it because i don't want to be in the
darkness i want to be in the light so
sing sing
is my gift to you okay that's
the most twisty tiny tease i've ever
heard so i'll take it
okay take it i don't know since a prison
that's all i know
so oh no
okay it's on the tip of my tongue oh
she's not been listening saying
no i won't no no you can't put that on
jesse no
that's just me trying to turn you know
the tables from darkness
this tunnel has no light at the end
let's pivot over here that's it exactly
that's where i'm at why were you in a
wonder woman costume not
on halloween important uh because i
think it's important to show that you
can be
wonder woman any time needed
and this was needed so yeah my timing is
always there's
always an answer or reason to what i do